une situation désespérée au yémen celle
alerte sanitaire que lance le haut
commissariat des nations unies aux
droits de l'homme
le couronne à virus inquiète mais il
n'est pas la seule préoccupation en
matière de santé à l'occasion d'un point
presse le porte parole de l'institution
onusienne a confié son pessimisme
nous craignons que d'innombrables vies
soient perdues non seulement à cause de
lakovic 19 mais aussi à cause du
paludisme du choléra de la dengue et
d'autres maladies
il n'ya tout simplement pas de lit peu
d'équipement peu de personnel est
pratiquement pas de médicaments des
informations terrible mais peu
surprenante à propos du système de santé
yéménite au début du mois le secrétaire
général adjoint des nations unies et est
revenu sur la somme récemment récolté
pour mettre fin à la crise humanitaire
une somme qui reste insuffisante nous
avons une conférence des donateurs l'an
dernier où d'entre vous étaient présents
et ce jour là nous avions répété 2,6
milliards de dollars avait un très bon
résultat ce sont environ un demi heure
de la fin mai le ministre de la santé du
gouvernement rebelle avait lui jugé
inefficace l'action d'une autre agence
onusienne
l' oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé les autres ni 3400 test mais ils
sont réhaussées de vias lausanne il ya
un bébé manar les tests ne sont pas
fiables
en d'autres termes l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles nous n'avons pas déclaré
le nombre de cas de coronavirus et
l'imprécision et l'inefficacité des
solutions à luz ont été fournis
ne dépendons pas des organisations je ne
pouvons pas compter sur elle à ce stade
ils n'ont pas soutenu le pays avec quoi
que ce soit pas même un seul médecin
ils attendent que l'aide arrive pour
soutenir les organisations maintenant
les personnes la lia d'achat dans un
pays miné par un conflit depuis presque
six années près de 20 millions de
personnes sont actuellement besoin de
soins de santé
selon handicap international